i went to the bank the other day
socially safe of course wearing my mask
and uh the tellers told me and this is
something that's interesting because
it's uh sort of a nationwide phenomenon
they told me they had run out of coins
did you know this was going on
apparently we're going through a coin
shortage yeah
you see it in lots of different stores
they say no change i guess it's like a
covid thing
yeah well anyway the u.s mint is
scrambling to figure out just what to do
and they just released this ad take a
look
hi i'm diana fowler director of the us
mint as an unforeseen side effect of
covid19
for some reason america is also now
experiencing a shortage of coins
we don't know why either so we're
introducing a replacement for coins
coivs coibs are just like coins except
they're actually
small rocks
clubs are about the same size as coins
and they come from the ground which
means we're less likely to run out of
them
and from now on all businesses have to
take them as legal tender
koips it's a new thing we're trying
because we ran out of coins
sorry can we cut um so i'm glenn a
writer at conan
um does this sketch idea like even
make sense at all oh
yeah yeah it's it's great yeah i've just
been spending a lot of time
inside by myself with like no one else
around
and since my brain just went like what
if what if coins were rocks
and like if you read the news at all
right now
like it's hard to be creative and make
stuff
oh absolutely i totally get it totally
yes
oh my god totally like me like i'm
trying to finish this novel so my
creative brain is not a little bit not
doing the
like good stuff because i'm just so
isolated right now
that i think i'm going crazy no no no no
no
absolutely not you are not losing your
mind i swear
the concept of the sketch is a little
weird
it's kind of it's a little i mean it
yeah
yeah would it be funny if the coins were
bugs
that's very fresh that makes sense
oh yeah thank you actor whose name i
don't remember okay
hi i'm from the us mint and coins is
bugs now
wow i enjoyed that didn't you andy yeah
it was good
yeah i think everyone enjoyed it
oh okay
great